nouveau numéro de reporter sur France 24
et c'est en Somalie que nous nous
rendons aujourd'hui dans l'est de
l'Afrique la sécheresse fait rage le
pays est habitué depuis des décennies
mais avec le changement climatique c'est
sécheresse se multiplient et s'accentue
entraînant la mort du bétail et la
famille des populations on estime que 7
millions de personnes sont aujourd'hui
en insécurité alimentaire en Somalie et
faute de financement internationaux
suffisant l'aide humanitaire peine à
arriver dans les régions reculées
Bastien Renouil s'est rendu dans la
région du poundland ou la situation est
particulièrement dramatique voici son
reportage Somalie le cycle de la famille
[Musique]
la Somalie est engagée dans une course
contre la montre perdue d'avance
la sécheresse est là dans l'état du
poundland il n'a pas plus depuis deux
ans les bêtes meurs et les hommes aussi
[Musique]
la nourriture se fait rare la famille de
menace
il faut d'urgence sauver ceux qui
peuvent encore l'être
[Musique]
Abdi 9 mois pèse 5 kg
sa mère l'a amené juste à temps dans ce
centre pour enfants sous-alimenter grâce
au traitement il devrait survivre malgré
de graves symptômes
il est déshydraté comme vous pouvez le
voir ça peut revient en place très
lentement ce qui indique une
déshydratation aiguë ainsi qu'une forte
malnutrition sa fontanelle est creuse ce
qui indique une déshydratation
importante ses yeux sont enfoncés vous
voyez il est aussi très faible il ne
peut même pas pleurer normalement
chaque semaine l'hôpital accueille des
dizaines de familles
730 en font sous nourris sont déjà morts
dans les hôpitaux du pays depuis le
début de l'année et beaucoup d'autres
n'ont même pas eu le temps d'accéder au
service de santé on périphérie de la
ville dans ce camp de déplacer
indispensable apporte les premiers soins
et tri des patients
ici aussi les enfants malnutrits se
succèdent
un traitement et qu'on lui donne un peu
de supplément alimentaire
ici je sais qu'ils vont s'occuper de lui
son fils ne sera pas hospitalisé elle
reçoit cette patte nutritive à base de
cacahuètes ainsi que quelques
médicaments
cela fait deux mois Kamina et ses 12
enfants habitent ici avec les déplacés
des autres familles
2011 2017 la Somalie est habituée aux
sécheresse mais avec le changement
climatique elle se multiplie et
s'accentue les aides de l'État sont
quasi inexistantes la Somalie est l'un
des pays les plus pauvres du monde et
aussi l'un des plus corrompus l'argent
n'arrive pas auprès de la population
alors l'aîné de la fratrie fabrique des
foulards qu'il revendront aux autres
déplacer
Amina elle peut enfin nourrir son
dernier né
nos chèvres sont morts notre survie
dépend des deux
alors après leur mort nous sommes venus
là
manquons
il y a de plus en plus de maladies
c'est vraiment dur que Dieu nous vienne
en aide
[Musique]
ici ils n'ont plus rien son mari trop
faible et rester au village un de ses
fils lui aussi malade n'a pas de
traitement faute d'argent
toutes leurs économies servent à acheter
un peu doux
on utilise cette eau pour nettoyer nos
vêtements pour cuisiner pour voir
ça coûte tellement cher
et même en y mettant le prix parfois on
ne parvient même pas en trouver
tout juste de quoi survivre
pourtant Garou et la capitale régionale
est moins affectée que le reste du
poundland
la rivière est asséchée mais il est
toujours possible de trouver de la
nourriture
les campagnes sont les plus affectées
c'est là que la duanitaire
internationale doit arriver en priorité
cette équipe de la FAO l'organisation
des Nations Unies pour l'alimentation et
l'agriculture va observer quels sont les
besoins les plus urgents
partout la population est menacée on est
dans une au niveau au niveau national on
est dans une situation où on a quasiment
quasiment la moitié de la population
7 millions un peu plus de 7 millions de
la population qui est en situation
d'insécurité alimentaire c'est énorme
c'est plus que ce qu'on n'a jamais eu
auparavant la dernière grande famille en
2011 avait causé 260000 morts
l'assistance humanitaire est complexe en
Somalie impossible d'accéder à la
totalité du territoire à cause du groupe
terroriste islamiste el Chabab
mais le principal obstacle reste le
manque d'argent la FAO a besoin de 268
millions de dollars pour répondre à
l'urgence humanitaire seul 25% de cette
somme ont pour leur été donné par les
bailleurs
l'équipe s'arrête dans le village de
Benders salam début 2022 ses habitants
recevaient chaque mois de l'argent de la
part de la FAO pour leur permettre de
continuer à vivre malgré la sécheresse
faute de moyens les versements ont été
stoppés depuis une grande partie de la
population a fui elle date les personnes
qui recevaient cette aide en dépendait
vraiment
avec la sécheresse le nombre de familles
dans le besoin a augmenté donc il faut
plus d'assistance ils doivent aider les
gens avec ce qu'ils peuvent
il faut une aide d'urgence
impossible de satisfaire immédiatement
le chef du village pourtant les
habitants qui n'ont pas encore fui ne
peuvent plus attendre
les températures caniculaires
fréquemment au-dessus de 40 degrés et
l'absence de pluie rende la vie
impossible
sans eau le bétail ne peut survivre
c'est l'un de nos réserves
il n'y a plus d'eau dedans depuis deux
ans
cela fait deux longues années qu'il n'a
pas été remplie par la pluie et la
situation est la même dans tous les
réservoirs des environs
regardez la végétation tout est sec
le seul magasin des environs a fermé
avec la sécheresse l'économie s'effondre
ici il n'y a plus rien pourtant Bender
salam attire tout de même des réfugiés
cette famille vient d'un village isolé
parmi les tous premiers à avoir été
affectés un million de personnes ont
déjà été déplacées depuis le début de la
crise
car un an que je suis là
depuis que la sécheresse nous a touchés
depuis que nous sommes arrivés nous ne
pouvons survivre que grâce aux gens du
village
nous n'avons rien on attend ici
c'est vraiment compliqué pour nous
d'accueillir ces gens
on ne peut pas les aider on a rien pour
eux on ne peut rien faire d'autre que
les hébergers c'est vraiment difficile
pour nous les responsables du village
à quelques kilomètres de la 125
travailleurs s'affairent
la FAO organise la construction de
petites digues elle retiendront l'eau
lorsque les pluies viendront en fin de
quoi faire pousser de l'herbe que pourra
manger le bétail
un projet à moyen terme qui permet aussi
d'aider les villageois immédiatement
ceux qui travaillent sont rémunérés
l'urgence aujourd'hui elle est faite
elle est climatique mais elle est aussi
financière et donc les gens ont besoin
d'un minimum de cash pour pouvoir
sur les sur les marchés sur les marchés
locaux de pouvoir se fournir pour les
biens de première nécessité
plus au nord la situation est encore
pire
les conditions climatiques sont
désastreuses
les vents forts entraînent des tempêtes
de sable les rafales dépassent les 100
km heure
l'équipe a reçu un signalement des
centaines de déplacés internes se sont
installés au milieu de nulle part ils
ont probablement besoin d'assistance
tout un village a fui la côte pour venir
à l'intérieur des terres ils attendent
ici depuis 40 jours mais aucune aide
humanitaire n'est encore arrivé
ici la côte est très loin ils ont dû
marcher plusieurs jours
nous avons eu un camion quand la
sécheresse s'est abattue pour fuir les
difficultés auxquelles nous devions
faire face nous nous sommes arrêtés ici
parce que nous ne pouvions pas aller
plus loin nous n'avions plus d'essence
donc c'est devenu notre destination
c'est là que nous nous sommes installés
ici il y a de l'eau à proximité mais
elle est salée c'est famillions quitté
un enfer pour un autre afin d'éviter une
telle situation il faudrait agir en
amont avant leur exode la chistange
qu'on aurait dû pouvoir amener
en ayant d'une part l'information et
d'autre part les financements surtout
les financements ça aurait été ce qu'on
fait par ailleurs un approvisionnement
en aliments du bétail tout ce qui est
fourniture de minéraux des vitamines des
campagnes de vaccination et surtout un
accès à aujourd'hui avec une fréquence
de choc climatique qui est quasi annuel
il est clair que même avec cette
assistance là c'est la survie même de ce
mode de vie donc de le pasturalisme et
remise en cause très clairement pour
essayer de réduire au maximum l'impact
de ces chocs il faut pouvoir les
anticiper
chose encore impossible pour le
gouvernement il y a un an faute d'argent
et d'infrastructures
mais depuis fin 2021 ces fonctionnaires
sont sur le terrain pour effectuer des
relevés et comprendre comment la météo
impacte leur pays
je mesure la profondeur de la nappe
phréatique
pour comparer entre son niveau d'avance
et celui en condition de sécheresse
toute la nappe phréatique du poinland
est appauvri
jour après jour son niveau diminue la
situation empire
leurs analyses effectuées les deux
hommes reviennent au centre de gestion
des informations
financées par l'Union européenne il
permet d'analyser la météo et son impact
les lieux sont encore en grande partie
vide mais l'existence d'une telle
institution est une avancée son
directeur prépare en entretien avec le
gouvernement et les prévisions sont
alarmants
comme les graphiques le prouvent la
sécheresse va encore empirer jour après
jour au pont de Land
ces informations aident le gouvernement
à prendre les bonnes décisions pour
préparer ces politiques et ses actions
pour lutter contre l'impact de la
sécheresse
aujourd'hui nous avons ce qu'il faut
pour effectuer un travail basique
mais nous avons besoin de plus d'argent
pour pouvoir travailler de la meilleure
façon possible
cet argent les autorités n'en disposent
pas pas plus qu'elles n'ont les moyens
d'aider leur population
la Somalie compte sur l'aide
internationale en attendant une
prochaine saison des pluies
mais faute de financement la situation
ne peut qu'empirer
2 millions d'enfants risquent la famille
au cours des prochains mois
voilà pour ce document signé Bastien
Renault c'est la fin de ce magazine
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de reporter sur France 24
[Musique]